[Música]
el coletazo de la tormenta Julia causó
en Venezuela fuertes precipitaciones y
el desbordamiento de cinco ríos
Arrasando las comunidades en tejerías
hay al menos 25 fallecidos y 52
desaparecidos
este lunes inicia en Los Ángeles un
nuevo juicio contra el ex productor de
Hollywood Harvey beinstein cuyos abusos
en el gremio del cine desencadenaron el
movimiento mitú por los derechos de las
mujeres hace cinco años
y el secretario general de la ONU
Antonio Gutiérrez respaldó el envío de
una fuerza de acción rápida a Haití para
detener las bandas armadas ser
responsables de la escasez de
combustible mientras la nación vive
brotes de cólera tenemos análisis
Estas son las noticias de América en
Francia 24 comenzamos en Venezuela hay
emergencia por el desbordamiento de
cinco ríos que dejó al menos 25 personas
fallecidas y 52 desaparecidas la
emergencia se produjo por las Fuertes
lluvias causadas por el coletazo de la
tormenta Julia que avanza por
Centroamérica la vicepresidenta de
Venezuela delcy Rodríguez informó que
las precipitaciones correspondientes a
un mes se acumularon el sábado en la
noche arrastrando troncos y escombros
sobre la comunidad de tejerías a unos 70
kilómetros de la capital Caracas
negocios y tierras de cultivos sufrieron
daños además las bombas de agua potable
fueron arrasadas en la zona nosotros
aquí el agua tuvimos que
sí y otros otros saltaron por allá por
la carretera
el temor de nosotros es la que se cayera
Pues de tu cultura
[Música]
este lunes inicia en Los Ángeles el
juicio contra el ex productor de
Hollywood Harvey beinstein El Magnate
está señalado por más de 90 mujeres por
acoso y abuso sexual y ya fue condenado
a 23 años de cárcel en Nueva York las
denuncias en su contra desataron el
movimiento mitú que destapó los abusos
sistemáticos en la escena
cinematográfica lluis Muñoz nos cuenta
una clase de actuación para preparar una
escena de sexo Claire worden enseña este
grupo de actrices Cuáles deben ser sus
límites
la mayoría de actores tienen una
historia en la que su consentimiento no
ha sido respetado o han tenido una
experiencia dolorosa en el set
especialmente en escenas con desnudos y
sexo y esto pasa con todos los actores y
géneros también durante la clase hay un
momento para aprender a ponerse una
tanga especial habitual en las escenas
sexuales
realmente lo que hacemos Es apoyar la
narración y garantizar que los actores
mantengan la autonomía de sus cuerpos
para que puedan dar su consentimiento a
lo que están haciendo y cuando los
actores se sienten escuchados atendidos
y apoyados consiguen hacer mejor su
trabajo
el movimiento mitó ha traído consigo una
nueva industria el de las coordinadoras
de intimidad las actrices lo celebran
la semana pasada estuve filmando escenas
de sexo luego me enteré de este tipo de
trabajo y dije este es el lenguaje y la
comunicación que se necesitan para este
tipo de escenas en los últimos cinco
años el movimiento mitú ha descubierto
las miserias de la industria
cinematográfica poniendo la lupa en
directores de la talla de Román Polanski
señalados de acoso sexual o el más
paradigmático el productor Harvey
weinstein cuyo juicio por crímenes
sexuales empieza este lunes en Los
Ángeles tras ya haber sido condenado a
23 años de prisión en Nueva York después
de ser acusado por más de 90 mujeres en
el sur de Estados Unidos la Industria
del gas se está comiendo las zonas
costeras desde que empezó la guerra en
Ucrania en febrero el país se ha
convertido en el mayor exportador de gas
natural el líquido del mundo esa
reciente proliferación de proyectos de
terminales de exportación irrita a los
residentes de la costa por la
contaminación que produce informe dele
aurel
a las puertas de su casa en Luisiana a
través de dar señala una terminal de
exportación de gas natural licuado y el
terreno que pronto podría albergar una
segunda lo que les dejaría sin otra
opción que hacer las maletas y dejar su
negocio de pescado se considera una
víctima colateral del desarrollo de la
industria gasística estadounidense que
la crisis del caso ruso ha convertido en
algo primordial
al final nadie quiere que una
corporación multimillonaria como esta
atropella a los pobres Pescadores no
puedes hacerme creer eso
no somos el precio del Progreso somos
seres humanos en el golfo de México se
encuentran cinco de las siete terminales
de exportación estadounidenses activas y
22 de los 24 proyectos presentados a las
autoridades un sacrificio de los
ecosistemas según este residente que
observa abatido como las olas provocadas
por Los buques metaneros devoran la
costa
ves los árboles que sean erosionado y
caído aquí se ve la erosión de la costa
hace un mes todos los árboles estaban en
la orilla
los militantes ecológicos denuncian la
incoherencia de una administración que
habla de emergencia climática y luego
aprueba este tipo de instalaciones en la
ciudad texana de portarturgia ya cuenta
con numerosas instalaciones
petroquímicas se temen los efectos a
largo plazos sobre la salud toman el
camino de menor resistencia Y eso es con
los pobres y los que no tienen acceso a
los abogados y que no están tan educados
o informados sobre lo que está pasando
según el registro de cáncer de Texas en
el condado la tasa de mortalidad por
cáncer es un 25% mayor que en el resto
del Estado
el secretario general de Naciones Unidas
Antonio Gutiérrez respaldó el pedido de
ayuda internacional de Haití para
combatir su crisis de violencia el
representante de propuso que uno o más
países envíen una fuerza de acción
rápida para ayudar a la policía local a
detener la amenaza que representan las
bandas armadas responsables de la
escasez de combustible previamente
conversa incluso Con Edison damas
analista político haitiano y miembro del
comité democrático haitiano en Argentina
le preguntamos si sería factible que
tropase de la ONU sean enviadas
sea factible porque ya está hecho el
perito de manera oficial por el gobierno
de Factoría pero este periodo es un
período hecho por este gobierno no es
realmente el pedido del pueblo haitiano
hay que tener en cuenta de que ellos ya
hace unos días empiezan a decir a no
escuchar los reclamos del pueblo por eso
mandaron este pedido el pueblo está
diciendo que no quieren una un envío de
fuerza pero ya se está definido que va a
ir uno una fuerza de la ONU en este
momento o de fuerzas internacionales de
otros países
en el territorio haitiano para
garantizar seguridad una seguridad una
violación de los violaciones de en Haití
que no datan de hoy que vienen ya de
muchos años y para el cierre un método
original es que ha demostrado su
eficiencia bailar para sentirse mejor y
reducir los síntomas de ciertas
enfermedades en Argentina la
tangoterapia es cada vez más conocida y
utilizada dirigida a personas en
situación de discapacidad pero también
adultos mayores este baile originario de
ese país ayuda a lidiar con la soledad y
a trabajar la motricidad de los
pacientes
es un ritual al que Cristian da mucha
importancia cada semana se prepara para
ir a bailarlo
[Música]
tiene unos chaqueta me gusta la ropa
esta me gusta el tango
Cristian un hombre argentino de 38 años
padece discapacidad intelectual desde su
infancia y cuando se somete a la
tangoterapia siente la plenitud de la
danza
tomen vos atravesar no no voy a dejar
atenderme bien no pensamos mucho dos
tres muy bien Rosario Beltrán profesora
de tangoterapia es la encargada del
curso una terapia suave que se adapta a
las necesidades de cada persona paso a
paso la danza mejora el equilibrio la
movilidad y también permite ganar
confianza en sí mismo algunos de los
pacientes los veo que antes no salían y
no querían bailar no hablaban y ahora Ya
empezaron a hablar un poco mejor
hay un chico no conoce los números pero
hoy hasta el 8 y él ya sabe qué número
es y qué movimiento es lo cognitivo se
desarrolló esta danza tirrapia se está
extendiendo por toda Argentina en el
norte del país está academia ofrece
información para poder enseñar a su vez
la tangoterapia María una enfermera está
convencida de sus beneficios
[Música]
si yo estoy enferma por eso es
importante en la salud para este
profesor de Tango las virtudes
terapéuticas del baile se explican por
su origen histórico
llevamos la gran cantidad de inmigrantes
sobre todos varones que llegaron a
nuestro país a estos comienzos del siglo
XX se encontraban solo del tango nació
como una necesidad que les permitió
sentirse contenidos la enseñanza de la
tangoterapia no está reservada a Los
profesionales de la salud es suficiente
con tener el ritmo en la piel
siga en Francia 24
[Música]